Take cropleek and garlic, of both equal quantities,
pound them well together… take wine and
bullocks gall, mix with the leek… let it
stand nine days in the brass vessel
While not exactly something Snape would assign,
new research shows this ancient potion might
have healing powers.
Hey muggles, Julia here for Dnews
So that sounds like something out of a spell
book eh?
Well actually it’s a remedy found in a thousand
year old Anglo-Saxon book.
Modern researchers found that this concoction
conjured up a cure for eye stye.
That’s when you get an annoying painful
bump on your eyelid, from an infected hair
follicle.
Scientists from University of Nottingham,
in England recreated the recipe using ingredients
as close to ancient as possible.
Which was a little tricky, I mean leek and
garlic have been bred over the centuries and
probably look pretty different from what the
recipe called for.
Wine was fairly easy, the researchers got
it from a historical vineyard, and the bullocks
gall?
Parts of cow stomach, was easy to get too.
After being mixed together and left to sit
for nine days, the researchers tested the
potion on scraps of mouse skin.
The skin had been infected with a super bug
version of MRSA.
Surprisingly, it worked!
It killed 90% of the bacteria, pretty much
equivalent to modern day antibiotics typically
used to treat MRSA.
The researcher found that it wasn’t just
one ingredient that killed of the bad bugs,
but the combination of them!
While this is rather exciting, this research
isn’t published yet, it will be presented
at the 2015 Society for General Microbiology
conference.
Other researchers tried to recreate the potion,
but it uh.. didn’t go so well.
Their concoction turned into a “loathsome,
odorous slime", so more research is needed.
As we face the rise of antibiotic resistant
superbugs like MRSA, looking into the past
might be the way forward.
Scientists think ancient cultures like Egyptians,
Chinese, Greeks and Nubians and many more,
were purposefully making antibiotics to use
in medicine thousands of years before the
discovery of penicillin in 1928, which marks
the dawn of the age of modern antibiotics.
Like, Sugar and honey have been used in dressing
wounds for over 4,000 years and can even be
traced back to the ancient Egyptians.
More recent research found that the Egyptians
were on to something.
Honey which is mostly made up of sugar, kills
bacteria with a kind of one-two punch.
High sugar concentrations draws out water
from bacteria, which basically kills them
through dehydration, but other properties
like honey’s acidity also hamper the bacteria.
This is different from modern antibiotics
which usually damage bacteria’s growth processes,
which bacteria is quickly able to develop
a resistance too.
Or maybe ancient cultures used beer to fight
bad bacteria.
One study published in the American Journal
of Physical Anthropology suggests that Ancient
Nubians, a people who lived in present day
Sudan, made “gold beer” with antibiotic
properties.
The researchers looked at bones from between
A.D. 350 and 550 and found traces of Tetracycline,
a type of antibiotic made from soil bacteria.
The researchers think the ancient culture
used the beer to treat certain diseases, just
like how Ancient Egyptians and Jordanians
used beer to treat gum disease.
There’s loads of other examples of ancient
medicine proving itself in modern times.
Like a Chinese plant used to fight malaria
or mugwort treating herpes.
Now I’m not saying all natural remedies
are effective, there are some shady shams
out there, but it’ll be a cool area of research
to keep an eye on.
Alright guys, what do you think?
What ancient remedy would you try?
Let us know in the comments below…